I want to point out that these are
algebraic fractions so first you've got
to know how to deal with its fractions
and then work out the algebra later okay
now we're dividing these two fractions
ago that's quite different to
subtracting if I gave you an example 3/4
divided by 2/5 I gave your paragraphs no
abrupt what would you do with those very
good I can take the reciprocal that flip
it upside down and that would have the
effect of changing division into
multiplication so that's what you're
going to do okay now I'm going to do
much safety here however when you have a
look at questions like this we know in
better to start like looking at common
factors and cancelling things out rather
just multiply through because the
numbers quickly get quite large and if I
can avoid big numbers then that water
brainless although more so when I look
at this there's so much algorithm that
even when I take this suggestions above
it right with me I am going to leave the
first fraction intact I'm going to
transfer the division into
multiplication which means that the
second fraction is now the reciprocal I
do not
once you just multiply the numerators
and then multiply it the derivative what
are the numerous for example do you
remember when you get given a binomial
like say it is when you expand this term
side if I know you have two terms this
paragon two terms so your answer is
going to have to tie to four terms if I
look at these numerators how many turns
out am you it's a free which we call a
trinomial is another three over here how
many turns will there be when you
multiply those together three times
three nine now one of them cancel I will
collect but I won't even go in there so
instead have a look at the third thing
every
a what strategy can help you before I
start to bind a little factorize let's
have a go at the table here H square
plus 5 h plus 6 or pair of numbers can
we be going to really six in one would
be would be what we use in one of these
were a negative but it's all positive
right now
yeah so six plus one eager to five
instead I'll go into in turn so I've got
h plus 2h plus 3 yeah
Donatas pair of numbers as before
multiplies the three three like
immediately you can see the advantage of
going to factorization first I haven't
even finished the question and I've
already got some things that will
eliminate each other
I'll get to the elimination in a minute
let's look at this other fraction H
squared minus 2h minus 3 Tara numbers 1
and negative 3 they'll add up to this
for them and they'll also note is so H
plus 1 H minus 3 last one this is
actually quite motivating that's a
bigger pair of numbers all you have to
do is take out the common factor which
in this case in H ok now we're ready can
go I advise you to pick another Colorado
through this step just so you know this
is uh presume badly in the first
fraction active or e CH + 3 + H + 3 so
therefore if I look across fractions you
actually can see this h plus 2 will
cancel with this edge multitude you'd be
that H 1 2 and h plus 2 Megan I got a
TLC H Plus Ones down to you the H plus 1
up there now the key thing you need to
remember when you're doing this if
you're calculating cancel cancelling
them from top and bottom cancel it at
the special key point are you can cancel
if for instance there's an X plus 1 here
NH was one down the bottom on the
denominator is your
you want to top one one next line what's
left of the different that's it
that's that's all the slack on the
denominator change and now you know
that's the hit we need especially ah
that's a great question can I cancel the
H okay of course forgive me if I gave
you like this for that now doing
shamanism just think about what this is
equal to now watch what happens if I
care to the force
I think like why can't it work this is
not the it's way differently it's this
one caught up because that's one them
for so what what went wrong why can't I
just cancel them towards Betty okay this
attraction that's a problem but wait is
it a problem why can't I mean I can lots
of kids like a video why can't I can't
save your malrotation
every week before if I cancel this for
down the bottom it's going to go through
everything with the top if you can't
just pick and choose
so in fact you can cancel the four if
you want but this is not what it looks
like
doesn't look like this it looks like
this you know you cancel here for over 4
is 1
well 3 over 4 is 3 over 4 and that it is
quarter okay so when you look over here
like I've just changed from done this
before - and h-hour obeys all the same
laws that promise because album is just
provable
can you cancel eh ads are well blow
because they're eminent each year if you
wanted to sometimes everybody missed
this but in this case there is not I
could do this HOH is one but then you
have that three image in that better I
know how to fix ideas and save is that
ok so I'm just going to leave it at that
line you're finished okay so just to
review we have a button come to my
digital sound bar it's just my fraction
your infractions division take the
reciprocal thirds of application but
secondly local practice once you fight
back to see just cancel like crazy and
your weather is very nice and simple
okay